Ok, donc nous sommes devant les qualifications des diacres.
C'est la leçon 4 sur ces cours à propos des diacres.
Je vous rappelle que c'est un cours particulièrement important pour notre vie d'église
car on n'a pas encore de diacres officiels.
Les diacres sont un office.
C'est un office très important pour une vie d'église ordonnée.
C'est important de vous rappeler en fait que même si on a plein de cultures différentes
d'églises dans leur organisation, ni toute tradition d'église sont en train de suivre
les paramètres bibliques tels qu'on retrouve dans les Écritures.
Donc les versets qu'on vient de lire 14 à 16, verset 14 particulièrement,
c'est intéressant de remarquer, Paul, l'apôtre, va écrire à Timothée en disant
« Je t'écris ces choses avec l'espérance d'aller bientôt vers toi,
mais afin que tu saches si j'étarde comment il faut se conduire dans la maison de Dieu. »
Donc c'est très important de nous rappeler, Dieu ne nous a pas laissé livrer à notre imagination
par rapport à la manière dont on doit gérer l'église.
La Bible est très claire par rapport au principe qui devrait gouverner l'église.
Donc quand on considère la notion des diacres ou l'église,
l'organisation de l'église, nous avons qu'il y ait deux offices formels
qu'on va retrouver dans l'église.
Donc on sait que certaines églises vont avoir des ouvriers, des évangélistes,
et toute une échelle pour arriver à devenir pasteurs, prêtres,
et vont même faire la différence entre anciens, pasteurs, évêques,
voire même papes ou des nouveaux apôtres dans nos jours.
Donc ce sont des choses qu'on ne retrouve pas dans les paramètres de la Bible.
Les seules choses qu'on va retrouver dans la Bible, c'est que Dieu a eu un travail fondationnel
à travers les apôtres, les prophètes, mais qu'ensuite la continuité de l'église
serait livrée à la direction des anciens, qui peuvent être synonymes des pasteurs ou des évêques,
et le douzième office, c'est les diacres.
Les anciens étant particulièrement impliqués dans l'instruction, dans l'enseignement,
et les diacres pour aider, pour assister avec tout ce qui pourrait être matériel
afin que les implications spirituelles soient protégées,
afin que les pasteurs puissent se consacrer à paître les troupeaux,
à enseigner et à se consacrer à la prière.
Donc, dans ces leçons qu'on a traversées jusqu'ici,
on a déjà considéré dans la première leçon quelle était la différence entre les rôles particuliers
des diacres par rapport au rôle des anciens.
Donc, on s'est rappelé en fait que les rôles des diacres, c'est un rôle de servir aux tables.
Donc, c'est très intéressant, c'est comme un serviteur dans un restaurant.
Et dans l'origine du ministère des diacres, les précourseurs des diacres,
ils étaient aussi littéralement appelés à résoudre un problème de distribution des nourritures.
Acte VI, c'était les précourseurs des diacres.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer qu'ils étaient engagés à dépanner les apôtres,
ceux qui étaient chargés de l'enseignement de la prière,
afin que la communauté ne souffre pas de la privation de leur nourriture la plus importante,
qui est la nourriture spirituelle.
Et donc, nous ne pouvons pas apprendre à chérir les ministères des diacres
si nous ne sommes pas en train de chérir avant tout l'importance du ministère,
des pasteurs qui soient véritablement qualifiés dans la prière et dans l'enseignement
pour préparer et pour prendre soin de nous spirituellement.
Donc, c'est un ministère qui est engagé aux choses pratiques,
mais qui a une implication très spirituelle.
Donc, la chose la plus spirituelle que les diacres peuvent faire,
c'est de dépanner les anciens pour qu'ils puissent se consacrer à la prière
et à la préparation de l'enseignement.
Et donc, on a traité l'importance de la distinction entre anciens et diacres
pour apprendre à chérir les rôles des diacres.
Et ensuite, on a traité plusieurs conceptions incorrectes, troublées des rôles des diacres.
Et c'était plus ou moins l'expérience de plusieurs d'entre nous
avec des mauvaises versions des diacres dans plusieurs églises.
Et nous sommes en train de marcher dans la direction d'une clarification biblique
de ce qui est les rôles des diacres.
Donc, on a traité avec Stéphane.
On est revenu au texte d'acte VI pour nous rappeler plus ou moins
quelles étaient les fonctions essentielles, originales des diacres.
Car même si acte VI, ce n'est pas encore l'institution formelle des diacres,
c'était l'opportunité qui a, on va dire, donné occasion,
qui a donné occasion à un exercice de ces ministères
d'une manière un peu plus fondamentale ou précourseure.
Et donc, par là, on a aussi, Stéphane a aussi pu toucher
à quelques qualifications des diacres qui sont fondamentales.
Et donc, notamment, si on revient à un acte VI,
nous allons remarquer quelques caractéristiques fondamentales des diacres
où, dans les versets 2 d'acte VI, ils vont dire
« Choisissez... »
Ils convoquèrent la multitude des disciples et dirent
« Il n'est pas convenable que nous laissons la parole pour servir au table »
et la prière pour servir... Pardon.
« La prière et la parole pour servir... Pardon. »
« Il n'est pas convenable que nous laissons la parole des dieux pour servir au table. »
« C'est pourquoi, frères, choisissez parmi vous cet homme
des qui l'on rende un bon témoignage,
qui soit plein d'esprit, sang et des sagesses
et qui nous chargerons de cet emploi. »
Ces paramètres seront retrouvés dans tous les passages bibliques.
qui vont décrire plus ou moins les rôles des diacres.
C'est-à-dire, nous allons voir beaucoup plus d'informations
qui touchent les caractères spirituels des diacres
que la description de leur travail.
Et ça, c'est très intéressant dans la Bible, comme on va remarquer.
Mais bon, ici, nous voyons quelques critères fondationnels.
Et ce que nous allons retrouver ici,
c'est particulièrement les qualifications.
Déjà, qu'ils soient chrétiens, qu'ils soient choisis
au-dedans de la communauté, d'entre vous,
parmi vous, cet homme, des qui on rende un bon témoignage.
Donc, leur réputation est déjà reconnue comme des hommes
qui ont une réputation confirmée, si on peut dire comme ça,
que leur maturité, leur intégrité spirituelle est évidente.
Qu'ils soient pleins de l'esprit saint.
Donc, c'est intéressant.
Parmi une communauté où tous sont habitation de saint-esprit,
c'est possible de remarquer certaines personnes
qui sont encore plus influencées par les saint-esprits,
par la manière dont ils sont en train de vivre,
et des sagesses,
qui est aussi une implication d'être remplis de saint-esprit.
Mais ici, c'est une sagesse particulièrement donnée à ces hommes,
un don du saint-esprit à ces hommes,
pour gérer des situations relationnelles,
c'est-à-dire pour exercer leur rôle en tant que diacre.
Donc, c'est intéressant de remarquer,
car nous allons nous concentrer surtout sur 1 Timothée 3 aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est très important de remarquer
que quelque part,
1 Timothée 3,
lorsqu'il va parler des qualifications des diacres,
c'est quelque part un développement
de ces éléments qu'on va retrouver déjà en acte 6.
C'est la conception avant tout
que les diacres, c'est un don des dieux pour l'Église,
et ce que les saint-esprits a donné à l'Église
pour accomplir cette fonction
ont été quelque part capacité
ou rendu capable par les saint-esprits
avec certains dons
et avec une spiritualité
quelque part au-dessous de la moyenne.
Mais nous allons revenir à ces considérations.
Donc, pourquoi c'est important
de faire cette remarque dès le départ ?
C'est car, comme on a déjà vu,
on peut partir des idées non bibliques
pour choisir quelqu'un
à occuper un ministère des diacres,
qui est un ministère très pratique
dans la vie de l'Église.
Leur aide est évidente.
Et plusieurs églises sont tentées
à trouver cette aide
de manière très pragmatique.
Donc, l'auteur de ces livres de 9 Max,
il va donner un cas imaginaire pour nous,
pour qu'on garde dans nos esprits
pendant qu'on avance dans cette leçon.
Et il va dire, imaginez, par exemple,
que Lucas est un homme d'affaires prospère,
Sabrina est une personne extrêmement généreuse,
Jean est capable de tout réparer,
Alex est membre depuis une quarantaine d'années,
Juan espère un jour devenir ancien,
sont-ils qualifiés pour être diacres ?
De nos jours, l'une des tragédies
de notre vie d'Église
se trouve dans les manques d'attention
que l'on accorde la définition biblique du diacre
à ce qui n'est pas.
Et donc, ce qui est intéressant ici,
c'est que les remarques faites
par rapport aux capacités de ces personnes,
ce sont des capacités
qui peuvent résoudre des problèmes
très pratiques dans la vie de l'Église,
mais elles ne se dirigent pas forcément à l'être.
On est plutôt dans la capacité de faire,
dans l'évaluation de la capacité de faire,
une capacité pragmatique
qui est dans la considération de l'être.
Quelles sont les motivations pragmatiques
qui peuvent tenter les Églises,
les anciens, les pasteurs,
à choisir certaines personnes ?
Par exemple, on peut penser, à nouveau,
à cette capacité intellectuelle
ou même relationnelle,
des personnes qui ont la facilité
d'avoir un bon trait avec les personnes.
On peut penser à des capacités,
comment on voit,
de réparer des choses pratiques
dans la vie de l'Église,
s'occuper même de l'installation
et gérer tous les médias.
C'est très intéressant de remarquer
que plusieurs personnes dans la communauté
sont très duées pour accomplir des tâches
et pour occuper des responsabilités
qui semblent aider de manière très pratique l'Église.
Mais en même temps,
si on donne à ces personnes-là
les titres de diacre
sans évaluer l'être,
on peut risquer d'établir
de manière visible et officielle
devant la communauté
des modèles, des serviteurs
qui ne peuvent pas être
les modèles bibliques,
les modèles des dieux pour cela.
Donc nous devrions apprécier
les possibles capacités
et la variété des capacités
et des services possibles pour le diacre.
Par contre, on ne commence pas par là.
Des fois, il y a des urgences
qui apparaissent dans la vie de l'Église
et on est tenté à cause d'une urgence
à déclarer certaines personnes
capables de résoudre ces problèmes
comme des diacres.
Il y a un désir de grandir vite,
d'organiser plus vite l'Église.
Il y a le désir de dépanner
vraiment les responsabilités pastorales
qui parfois sont cumulées
et qui vont sortir du cadre
des responsabilités prioritaires d'un pasteur.
Mais parfois, il vaut mieux
qu'un pasteur soit surchargé
avec certaines choses
qu'il y ait des données
en titre aussi important
à des personnes
qui ne sont pas qualifiées bibliquement.
Parfois, il y a des attentes
qui sont mal placées
envers les personnes.
Et parfois, il y a des personnes
qui vont même faire usage
de ces titres des diacres
comme un moyen de développement
pour la personne.
Il y a une personne
qui n'est pas trop accrochée
à la vie de l'Église,
qui n'est pas en train
de servir nulle part.
Cette personne-là
est plutôt en train
d'osciller dans la foi
et elle n'est pas aussi tant engagée.
Peut-être qu'ils se sont donnés
une responsabilité
ou un titre à cette personne,
elle allait s'accrocher.
Et la raison,
ou les raisonnements,
il est plutôt l'inverse.
C'est par la prédisposition
à servir,
par l'engagement dans les services,
c'est par l'assiduité
de ces personnes-là,
c'est par leur intégrité
testée et attestée
que nous allons identifier
chez ces personnes-là
les qualifications pour les ministères
et par l'inverse.
Les ministères des diacres
et aucune responsabilité à l'Église
ne devraient être un moyen
de développer les personnes.
Bien sûr que nous serons tous développés
pendant qu'on sert,
mais la prédisposition à servir
et la fidélité dans les services
viennent avant, quelque part,
la confirmation
de cette qualification.
et donc il faut qu'on soit
très attentifs
à ces avertissements
car nous pouvons être tentés
par des raisons très pragmatiques
à distribuer des titres
qui sont très importants
selon les critères bibliques.
Et donc,
quelle est l'emphase biblique ?
L'emphase biblique,
elle est claire.
L'être vient toujours avant
les fers
car si Dieu est derrière
ces dons
qu'il donne à l'Église,
si un diacre,
elle est produit
de l'agence surnaturelle
des dieux entre nous,
ce n'est pas à nous
de chercher à fabriquer un diacre,
produire un diacre,
c'est à nous de reconnaître
ces dons
qu'il donne à l'Église.
Et donc,
comment nous pouvons
ou comment nous devons reconnaître ?
C'est ça
qu'on va considérer aujourd'hui.
L'écriture,
elle est très vague
sur les détails
de ce que les diacres
doivent faire.
Elle parle beaucoup plus
sur ce qui qualifie un diacre.
Elle parle peu
sur la façon
d'exercer les ministères
dans la pratique
dans l'Église.
Mais les soins de la Bible,
c'est de nous apprendre
beaucoup
sur la vision des dieux,
sur qui est le diacre,
qui sont ces personnes
qui vont occuper quelque part
une place
des directions
dans l'Église.
L'être
est plus important
que ce qu'il fera.
Et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que c'est par des saints divins
que la Bible
nous donne
beaucoup plus
de flexibilité,
on va dire,
d'imagination
par rapport
à comment
les diacres
peuvent servir.
OK ?
Car,
même si la Bible,
elle a été écrite
il y a longtemps,
ses principes
sont toujours pertinents
et pour toujours pertinents.
Et c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
les fers peuvent varier
selon les temps,
selon les caractéristiques
de notre génération,
selon les contextes.
Et nous pouvons imaginer
des exercices
qu'un diacre
peut faire aujourd'hui
qui n'avait pas de place
pour être faits
à l'époque des Paul
lorsqu'il a écrit
à Timothée.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que si nous avons
une personne
spirituellement qualifiée,
mature,
remplie de son esprit,
c'est clair
qu'elle ne risquera pas
aussi tant
de devenir un modèle
lâche pour la communauté.
Et donc,
il vaut mieux
on va dire
casser notre tête
pour découvrir
comment cet homme
appelé
à être diacre
il peut servir
qu'il est
de mettre n'importe qui
dans un rôle
des responsabilités
au sein de l'Église.
Et donc,
l'accent biblique
est beaucoup plus mis
sur la pureté
et la profondeur
spirituelle
de ses dirigeants
qui est sur ses capacités,
sur ses habiletés.
Donc,
malheureusement,
dans nos jours,
on semble être plus dirigé,
même pour les prédicateurs,
à la capacité humaine,
les habiletés humaines
des communications
qui est
les caractères spirituels.
Mais lorsqu'une Église
considère d'installer
un diacre,
elle doit regarder
avant tout
ce que la Bible présente
comme qualification biblique.
Donc,
pour rappel,
acte 6,
nous venons de lire,
qu'ils soient chrétiens,
donc parmi vous,
parmi la communauté,
qu'ils aient déjà
un bon témoignage,
qu'ils soient
pleins du Saint-Esprit
et des sagesses.
Ces quatre critères
vont se développer
d'une manière
un peu plus formelle
et officielle
et c'est important,
en 1er Timothée 3.
Donc,
quand on est
à 1er Timothée 3,
nous sommes déjà devant
les rôles du diacre
formalisé,
institué,
un office
de l'Église.
OK ?
Et donc là,
on a un développement
des paramètres
qui nous sont donnés
de manière plus claire
dans ces passages.
Et donc,
qu'est-ce qu'on doit observer
dès le départ ?
C'est que les critères
de qualification
pour un diacre
et qui touchent
avant tout
l'être du diacre,
ce sont
des conditions
solennelles,
perpétuelles
et non négociables.
OK ?
Ce sont des conditions
universelles
et perpétuelles.
Donc,
il n'y a aucune Église
qui puisse dire
les temps ont changé,
on va utiliser
d'autres critères
pour choisir un diacre.
Et ce n'est pas
qu'il y ait une lettre
qui peut l'écrit
de manière personnelle
à Timothée.
Donc,
les textes,
il est clair.
Si on revient
au verset 14,
1er Timothée 3,
verset 14,
donc lisons ensemble.
J'ai écrit ces choses
avec l'espérance
d'aller bientôt
vers toi,
« Mais afin que tu saches
si j'étarde
comme il faut
se conduire
dans la maison des dieux. »
Donc,
« Comme il faut »,
ce n'est pas tout simplement
comme toi,
toi,
tu dois te conduire,
mais c'est comme
il faut n'importe quelle personne,
n'importe quel endroit.
Et beaucoup d'autres passages
chez Timothée
nous montrent,
par exemple,
lorsque Paul va dire
« Je veux donc
que les hommes
prient en tout lieu. »
C'est clair
que cette lettre
n'était pas
qu'exclusive
aux églises
d'Éphèse
où Timothée
était en train
de servir.
Non,
c'était des lettres
qui devraient
circuler
toutes les églises
de l'époque
et toutes les églises
de toutes les époques.
Et donc,
ces critères
sont perpétuels
et sont universels.
La première chose
à remarquer,
c'est comment
il faut se conduire,
comment on doit
se comporter,
c'est comment on doit
gérer la maison des dieux.
Donc,
ce sont des conditions
universelles
pour l'Église
de tous les temps.
Une autre chose
importante à remarquer,
ce sont des conditions
solennelles,
c'est-à-dire
les seules personnes
qualifiées
pour instruire
la communauté,
c'est ce que Paul
entendait faire
envers Timothée
et Timothée
doit faire
envers son église.
Donc,
ces personnes-là
qui vont instruire
la communauté
à choisir
un diacre
et les diacres
qui vont occuper
une position
de leadership
dans cette église,
une position officielle
ces personnes
qui occupent
cette position,
même si tous
les chrétiens
doivent avoir
la crainte des dieux
en sens des responsabilités
et des rédivabilités,
ces personnes-là
qui occupent
l'église
des chypes
devraient être
les personnes
les plus sensibles
à cette rédivabilité
qu'on a devant Dieu.
Donc,
c'est-à-dire
lorsqu'il est en train
d'écrire à Timothée
et qu'il dit
« j'espère bientôt
te voir »,
là,
il est déjà
en train de dire
les thèmes,
c'est
comment procéder
dans la maison des dieux.
Et la première chose
que Timothée doit attendre,
ce n'est pas tout simplement
que Paul vienne
avec son amour
des bergers
pastorales,
c'est qu'il y a certains,
mais c'est l'apôtre
du Christ
qui vient
visiter mon église.
Et donc,
c'est déjà
en sens
des rédivabilités.
j'ai écrit ces choses
sachant que dans mon absence,
comment il faut
se porter dans la maison des dieux.
Mais il y a beaucoup plus
que la présence
d'autorité de l'apôtre,
il y a aussi
quelque chose
de très intéressant ici,
mais afin que tu saches,
si j'étarde,
donc même si l'apôtre
n'est pas là,
comme c'est le cas
pour nous aujourd'hui,
même si l'apôtre
n'est plus là,
nous devons savoir
comment il faut
se conduire
dans une maison
qui n'est pas nôtre,
dans la maison
des dieux.
C'est la propriété des dieux.
Je ne peux pas gérer
cette maison
à ma manière.
Je dois gérer
cette maison
selon les goûts des dieux,
à la manière des dieux.
OK ?
Qui est l'église
de Dieu vivant ?
Et là,
c'est pour terrifier,
car quand la Bible
nous parle de Dieu vivant,
c'est pour parler
d'un Dieu
qui a un zèle
super présent,
toujours présent,
dans une église
qui soit légitime,
car il y a
plusieurs églises
qui ne sont plus
la maison des dieux.
Comme dans les
passages de l'Ancien Testament,
la gloire des dieux
était déjà
bien éloignée
de l'arche de l'Alliance.
Icabod,
la gloire des dieux
était déjà partie.
Et donc ici,
si une église
est véritablement
la maison des dieux,
les dirigeants
de cette église
doivent avoir
la crainte
de gérer l'église
selon la volonté des dieux.
Donc,
comme il faut
se conduire
dans la maison des dieux,
qui est l'église
du dieu vivant,
un dieu qui est
un zèle énorme
envers sa propre maison,
qui est
la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité.
Et vous allez remarquer
que pour
ce rappel,
cette exhortation
de l'apôtre Paul,
d'éveiller
la crainte
chez Timothée
afin qu'il n'ose
pas installer
comme diacre
ceux qui ne sont
pas qualifiés,
ni les anciens,
car c'est le même passage
dont il parle
des anciens
et il parle
des diacres.
Et donc,
Timothée devrait
avoir cette crainte
renouvelée
de ne pas imposer
ses manques
précipitamment
sur personne,
mais de respecter
les qualifications
bibliques,
car chaque qualification
biblique
a un rapport
envers ses ailes
des dieux,
envers l'autorité
qui couvre l'église,
envers cette notion
des conduites
dans la maison des dieux,
et envers le fait
que l'église
est la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité.
De la même manière
que l'église
est la maison des dieux,
ceux qui doivent être
les plus évidemment
l'habitation des dieux,
c'est-à-dire remplis
du Saint-Esprit,
ce sont ses dirigeants,
les anciens
et les diacres,
bien qu'il y ait
toute la communauté
et dans la communauté,
on a toujours
la possibilité
de retrouver
des personnes
qui sont encore
plus remplies
du Saint-Esprit
que les pasteurs
ou que les diacres,
que ce soit clair.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que même si nous tous
pouvons être également
remplis et vivre en réveil,
la réalité,
c'est qu'il y a
quelques places
qui ne peuvent pas
être occupées
si cela n'est pas le cas.
Et donc la réalité ici,
c'est que si l'église
est la maison des dieux,
les meilleurs représentants
de la maison des dieux,
ce sont ceux
qui sont remplis
des dieux
comme cette maison.
L'église du dieu vivant,
des personnes
qui affichent
par leur vie,
par leur comportement
que Dieu est vivant
entre nous.
La colonne
est l'appui de la vérité,
ce sont des personnes
qui ont ses ailes,
on va voir,
c'est un critère aussi
pour les diacres,
pour les mystères
de la piété.
Et là,
il va présenter
ces mystères de la piété.
Donc les enjeux
de l'évangile
qui sont rappelés ici,
donc lisons verset 16,
sans contredire,
les mystères de la piété
sont grands,
c'est lui qui a été
manifesté en chair,
justifié par l'esprit,
vu des anges,
prêché aux gentils,
cru dans les mondes,
élevé dans la gloire.
Qu'est-ce qu'il est
en train de rappeler
à Timothée ?
Paul est en train
de rappeler à Timothée
la réalité concrète
de l'évangile
qui a divisé l'histoire
avec les dieux
qui s'est fait hommes,
qui a été justifié,
manifesté en chair,
justifié par l'esprit.
Comment ?
Par les miracles
qu'il a opérés,
par la résurrection
surtout et avant tout.
Vu des anges,
prêché aux gentils,
cru dans les mondes,
élevé dans la gloire.
C'est-à-dire,
il est là,
à la droite du Père,
dans la place
des suprêmes autorités.
Il reviendra pour juger.
Rappelle-toi, Timothée,
avant de craindre les hommes,
avant d'être tenté
à favoriser ces membres
qui sont là
depuis longtemps
dans l'Église
et qu'on n'a jamais donné
une responsabilité officielle
ou formelle.
Attention, Timothée,
tu n'es pas là
pour plaire les hommes,
tu es là pour plaire Dieu.
C'est la maison des dieux.
Vous comprenez ?
Vous devez craindre
avant tout
Dieu lui-même
avant de craindre
aux personnes.
Donc, quelque part,
tout est condensé
dans cette exhortation
solennelle
qui se trouve
dans ces passages.
Mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
de quelles choses
il parle.
Et là, en fait,
c'est intéressant,
il parle des qualifications
pour les anciens
et pour les diacres.
Et ce qu'il faut retenir,
donc c'est,
voilà,
ce sont des conditions
universelles
ou perpétuelles,
ce sont des conditions
solennelles
et ce sont des conditions
non négociables.
Donc, les qualifications
qui sont fondées
sur les ailes des dieux
sur sa maison
parlent des sécheuses
que les diacres
et que les anciens
doivent être.
Ce n'est pas
tout simplement
il serait bien
s'ils sont comme ça.
Certains d'entre eux
pourraient être comme ça.
C'est mieux
si c'est comme ça.
Non, ce n'est pas
de tout ça.
C'est ils doivent être.
Ils doivent être.
Et c'est quelque chose
dont on doit remarquer.
Ils doivent être
malgré
toutes leurs capacités
et leurs habilités.
Il y a quelque chose
qu'ils doivent être
avant de faire
quelque chose
de manière officielle
à l'Église.
Et donc,
quelles sont
ces qualifications
que nous allons retrouver ?
La première chose
qu'il faut dire
c'est que ces qualifications
sont des qualifications
spirituelles.
Donc,
tous les ministères
au sein de l'Église,
quand on va lire
Ephésiens chapitre 4
par exemple,
nous parlent
du fait
que c'est Dieu lui-même
qui donne à l'Église.
Et si c'est
l'esprit des dieux
qui donne à l'Église
ces hommes,
nous devons nous rappeler
en fait que
ce qui caractérise
ces qualifications,
c'est la spiritualité
de ces personnes-là.
Donc,
c'est aucun mérite
d'eux-mêmes,
ni pour les anciens,
ni pour les diacres.
Ce sont des personnes
qui ont reçu
de la part des dieux
une mesure des grâces
qui agit.
c'est comme Augustin,
il avait l'habitude
de dire,
Dieu,
je te remercie
pour les péchés
qui tu m'as pardonnés,
mais je te remercie
peut-être encore plus
pour ta grâce
qui m'a empêché
de commettre d'autres.
Sans aucun orgueil
de ne pas avoir tombé
dans un péché ou l'autre.
Avec profonde conscience
de sa pauvreté spirituelle.
Mais nous,
en tant qu'église,
nous devons savoir
et reconnaître
que Dieu,
par sa grâce,
a donné une certaine
mesure
des grâces extraordinaires
pour faire ressortir
certains d'entre nous
avec une spiritualité
où le remplissage
du Saint-Esprit
est évident.
Et ces personnes
sont les modèles
pour la communauté.
Ils devraient nous inspirer
car c'est la même grâce
de Dieu
qui agit en nous
et qui agit en eux.
Mais si Dieu a décidé
selon la proportion,
comme Paul va dire
à Timothée au Corinthien,
selon la proportion
de la mesure des grâces.
Même l'apôtre Paul
fait la distinction
entre les mesures des grâces
entre apôtres et apôtres.
Lorsqu'il va comparer,
moi,
je suis né
comme un avorton,
un apôtre appelé plus tard.
Par contre,
moi,
j'ai travaillé
beaucoup plus que.
Par contre,
toutefois,
ce n'est pas moi-même
mais la grâce
de Dieu
qui agit en moi.
Et la Bible nous parle
que nous devons être
dans les contentements
selon l'appel
qui Dieu nous a donné
dans les corps
car Dieu nous a donné
tous une fonction
dans les corps
selon la mesure des grâces
que chacun a reçues.
Et donc,
tous les mérites
sont à Dieu.
Aucune comparaison
entre nous-mêmes
serait valable
mais nous devrions
tous être diligents
à trouver notre place
dans les corps
et nous rappeler,
en fait,
que quand on réfléchit
par les efforts humains,
comme si ces qualifications
que nous allons considérer
pouvaient être reproduites
et produisent
par nos propres efforts,
là,
on va très mal.
Ce n'est pas,
par exemple,
quelqu'un qui n'est pas
addictique
ou adonné au vent,
ce n'est pas
que ce soit une personne
qui soit toujours
en train de lutter
contre ça
pour donner une apparence
d'abstinence
devant les personnes.
C'est quelque chose
qui a plutôt
une évidence
d'une action
de Saint-Esprit
dans sa vie
où c'est beaucoup
plus facile pour lui
de dire non.
ou n'est pas
être tenté
par un gant sordide.
Ce n'est pas
que cette personne
est toujours
en train de lutter
contre un désir
constant
d'être plus riche.
C'est une personne
qui a été élevée
à une compréhension
et une expérience
plus concrète
avec la réalité
de l'Évangile,
la richesse
de la gloire future
et céleste
qui a la capacité
de vivre dans ces mondes
de manière
détachée
des biens
qui sont là.
Et donc,
ces caractéristiques,
elles ne sont pas
des choses
qu'on puisse fabriquer
par nos propres efforts.
Ce sont des qualités
spirituelles,
ce sont des qualités
qui sont les résultats
d'un impact,
d'une injection
des grâces
du Saint-Esprit
dans ces personnes.
Pourquoi ?
Car le Saint-Esprit
a décidé
de les capaciter
à fond,
notamment,
d'exercer
ce ministère.
Et donc là,
nous sommes tout simplement
en train de contempler
un phénomène
engendré par le Saint-Esprit
afin de reconnaître
quelle est sa place
dans le corps du Christ
pour les biens
de toute l'Église.
Et donc,
ce sont des qualifications
spirituelles.
Nous pouvons faire
une division
utile
pour distinguer
les qualifications,
par exemple,
morales
ou plutôt personnelles
ou internes
et les qualifications
relationnelles
dans ces passages.
mais il faut nous rappeler
toujours que,
peu importe quelles soient
les distinctions
qu'on fasse
entre ces vertus,
qu'on les voit
toutes comme un ensemble
inséparable,
plusieurs facettes
d'une œuvre
de Saint-Esprit,
d'une personne
remplie de Saint-Esprit,
et qu'on voit aussi
les faits
qu'elles sont
avant tout spirituelles.
C'est l'œuvre
de Saint-Esprit
inséparable.
Peut-être que
chez certains,
certaines facettes
vont ressortir
plus que d'autres,
mais d'une manière générale,
nous ne pouvons pas
avoir une personne
qui soit,
par exemple,
digne,
éloignée
de la duplicité
et éloignée
des excès
du vent,
mais qui
est tentée
par les gants sordides.
Donc là,
elle est disqualifiée.
Ce n'est pas
de décrocher
presque toutes les cases,
c'est de décrocher
toutes les cases
dans une mesure
suffisante
et évidente.
OK ?
Donc voilà
l'aspect spirituel.
Mais nous allons
distinguer
entre les qualifications
personnelles
ou morales,
comment les caractères
spirituels
s'affichent
chez cette personne,
OK,
de lui-même
et comment,
dans un autre moment,
on va considérer aussi
quelques caractéristiques
qui parlent plus
sur des qualifications
plutôt relationnelles.
personnelles,
comment il exerce
ou comment il exprime
son caractère spirituel
dans la manière
dont il se rapporte
à d'autres personnes.
OK ?
Donc,
nous allons
parcourir les textes
et considérer
ces qualifications.
d'abord,
les qualifications
morales.
Donc ici,
je vous suggère
quatre qualifications
personnelles
du caractère
spirituel.
Donc,
la première,
c'est tout-inclusive,
c'est cette notion
de dignité.
Donc,
1 Timothée 3,
8,
les diacres aussi
doivent être dignes.
Donc,
ces mots,
ces termes,
il est vraiment
très riche.
Ça parle d'un côté
d'une personne
qui est honorable,
qui inspire
les respects.
OK ?
C'est pas qu'il soit parfait,
mais qu'il soit
humble,
répentant
et exemplaire.
Ça,
c'est très important.
Car parfois,
on a l'impression
qu'une personne
au-dessus des réproches
ou digne,
c'est une personne
qui ne peut jamais
démontrer
ses faiblesses.
Mais ce n'est pas
un modèle
de leadership
pour les chrétiens.
Les chrétiens,
il est plus connu
par le fait
qu'il ne reste pas
dans un même péché
et par la manière
comme il réagit
en péché
qu'il est par le fait
de ne pas péché.
Donc,
dans cette retraite
récente que j'étais
avec les missionnaires
des Hard Cry
la semaine dernière,
l'une des choses
qui a ressorti,
c'est qu'un de nos
coordinateurs
des missions,
il a dit
que quand je vais
visiter les travaux,
je pose toujours
une question
très importante
et c'est
quelle était
la dernière fois
où tu as demandé
un pardon
d'une erreur
qu'il t'a commise
publiquement
ou à une personne
contre qui tu as péché ?
Car on a l'impression
que les pasteurs
ne pèchent pas.
Et lui,
il a raconté
cette histoire
en disant
que cet homme
qui était très connu,
un pasteur
très célèbre,
là où il est,
là où il sert,
un homme fidèle
et il a dit
avec tristesse,
je dois avouer
qu'il y a deux semaines,
j'ai dû m'élever
devant toute la communauté
et demander pardon
à une sœur
qui était assise
car une semaine avant,
elle a posé une question
dans une séance
des questions-réponses
et j'ai fait une blague
basée sur sa question
et tout le monde a riolé
et je n'arrivais plus
à dormir.
Et donc,
je suis revenu
pour demander pardon.
c'est les types
des choses,
des comportements,
des modèles
d'humilité
qu'on cherche
à identifier
dans un vrai chrétien,
dans un chrétien mature,
dans un homme
rempli de Saint-Esprit
car c'est l'une
des évidences
que nous sommes
sensibles au Saint-Esprit,
c'est si la sensibilité
à l'appel
à la répentance
est plus forte
que notre désir
charnel et humain
de préserver
notre réputation
basée sur nos propres efforts.
Et donc,
par là,
nous sommes devant
une personne
qui doit être digne
à tous égards.
Et c'est intéressant,
un homme
de dignité,
c'est un homme
qui est digne
de respect,
c'est la racine
biblique,
c'est quelqu'un
qui a une mentalité
sérieuse.
OK ?
C'est quelqu'un
qui traite
la vie humaine
par la manifestation
suprême
de sa dignité.
Cette capacité
qu'il doit avoir,
par exemple,
un diacre
selon Acte VI
et d'autres exemples
dans l'histoire
de l'Église,
de prendre soin
de ceux qui sont
pauvres,
ceux qui sont
opprimés,
dans les challenges,
il doit avoir
un égard
envers la dignité
de la vie
pour qu'il
puisse
chercher
à élever
la vie humaine,
promouvoir
la vie de l'autre
à une condition
de dignité
de l'image
de Dieu
sans mépriser
les personnes
vis-à-vis
à leurs circonstances
ou leurs conditions.
C'est quelqu'un
qui devient digne
non seulement
car il s'éporte
de manière digne
mais c'est une personne
prédisposée
à dignifier
la vie
et les autres.
C'est quelqu'un
qui fait tout
pour la gloire
des dieux,
par exemple.
On va consacrer
une leçon
pour parler
de l'excellence
du service,
de nous rappeler
par exemple
des puritans
qui,
lorsque les persécuteurs
venaient chercher
un puritans,
l'une des choses
qui l'identifiaient
les puritans
au milieu du travail
pour les menousies
qui travaillent
avec les bois,
c'est ça ?
C'était de voir
par exemple
dans les chaises
de la tourner
à l'inverse
et de voir
si c'était bien poli
là où personne
n'allait regarder
car c'était bien poli
car il faisait
tout pour la gloire
des dieux.
Et donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a conscience
de la dignité
des dieux,
qu'il est en train
de servir avant tout
à Dieu
et il va tout faire
avec excellence
pour la gloire
des dieux.
Et donc c'est cette notion
de dignité
qui regarde la vie
et la condition humaine
d'une manière sérieuse
qui, bien sûr,
a la joie de vivre
mais qui n'est pas toujours
en train de rigoler
surtout avec des choses
spirituelles,
avec des choses
qui impliquent
les destins éternels
des âmes.
Donc ils ont la conscience
et ça c'est intéressant
qu'en cherchant
les sommets
de la dignité humaine
le mieux qu'ils peuvent faire
c'est de libérer
à nouveau
les anciens
les pasteurs
pour équiper
la communauté
pour instaurer la communauté
pour prier pour la communauté
et donc ils vont faire
leur travail
avec sens de dignité
envisageant
l'excellence
et la dignité
en tout ce qu'ils font
et surtout
aux choses
qui se rapportent
aux choses spirituelles.
Ensuite,
car on doit avancer
et là c'est plutôt
des expressions
de cette dignité
dans plusieurs eres
car cette première qualité
elle est toute inclusive
mais la parole
nous parle aussi
qu'ils sont
éloignés
de la duplicité
dans l'original
ils ne doivent pas
avoir
une langue
double
ok
qui a bien sûr
dans plusieurs passages
la même connotation
des duplicités
même des cœurs
et donc
ces personnes
ne sont pas
données
comment vous appelez
gossip
qui ne sont pas
données
aux commérages
qui disent
une chose
à une personne
une autre chose
à l'autre
et pourquoi
c'est important
car
ils jouent un rôle
des réconciliations
ensemble de l'église
des préservations
de l'unité
de l'église
et ils seront
exposés
à plusieurs reprises
à plusieurs
à écouter
à responsabiliser
plusieurs versions
d'une histoire
et c'est que
l'une des choses
qui est l'un des plus grands défis
et même pour les anciens
c'est
de savoir
instruire les personnes
lorsqu'ils sont en train
de nous raconter
ces histoires
besoin d'aide
lutte contre un péché
ou réconciliation
avec des problèmes
avec d'autres personnes
c'est de savoir
que nous ne pouvons pas
encourager les personnes
à dire plus
ce qu'elles peuvent dire
pourquoi ?
car même si
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
le suprême sacrificateur
a la capacité
de tout écouter
sans changer
l'image exacte
qu'il a
de chacun d'entre nous
un pasteur
ou un diac
n'a pas cette capacité
je dois
empêcher
une personne
de dire des choses
qui puissent
représenter un péché
des diffamations
envers l'autre
frère ou soeur
je dois
empêcher moi-même
que mon image
d'une personne
dans la communauté
soit abîmée
par des paroles
nuisibles
qu'on est en train
de me raconter
donc pour protéger
moi-même
et pour protéger
la personne
qui raconte l'histoire
on doit dire
raconte les minimum
nécessaires
et nous allons
traiter les choses
les plus importantes
et pourquoi
c'est particulièrement
un appel
ou une qualification
pour les diacres
c'est qu'à plusieurs
reprises
à plusieurs niveaux
les diacres
ils seront
plus actifs
en ayant accès
aux maisons
de personnes
même que les anciens
car il y a
plusieurs
besoins
pratiques
pour les vies
des personnes
pour ceux qui sont
dans les besoins
etc
que les diacres
doivent se faire
présents
pour aider
dans les questions
pratiques
en déménagement
on a besoin d'aide
ou même
des personnes
qui sont dans
les besoins
de nourriture
etc
donc dans la
reconnaissance
dans l'histoire
de l'église
les rôles
des diacres
il est pratique
pragmatique
à plusieurs égards
et ils finissent
pour avoir
plus de contacts
avec les membres
de l'église
ils sont comme
les catalyseurs
de l'enseignement
des anciens
et pour
sécuriser
les besoins
pratiques
de l'église
il y a plusieurs reprises
ils sont là
en train d'entendre
plusieurs histoires
différentes
et ils doivent
d'abord
ne pas dire
ce qu'ils ne doivent pas dire
ils ne doivent pas
entendre
tout ce qu'ils aimeraient
et qu'ils ne devraient
même pas aimer
entendre
ils doivent savoir
quand arrêter
d'écouter
de parler
il faut qu'il soit
impartial
et il faut qu'il ait
cette capacité
en cherchant
de préserver
la dignité
et les mieux
des membres
de l'église
encourager
même
par exemple
les personnes
qui sont dans
les besoins
mais qui sont
timides
à demander
car ils peuvent
avoir peur
que les partager
leurs défis
et leurs challenges
soient diffusés
à toute la communauté
et donc
ces hommes-là
ils doivent garder
bien leur langue
leur parole
et pas se montrer
intéressés
à tout savoir
et c'est intéressant
ni parler
une chose
à une personne
et autre
à l'autre personne
car les motivations
c'était plutôt
la réconciliation
mais les moyens
n'étaient pas
du tout bibliques
ni sans
et donc on doit
être vrai
dans ce qu'on dit
donc ni dire
des choses différentes
ni dire une chose
et agir
une autre
par exemple
si on va
je vais me confier
un diacre
je vais visiter
une famille
de l'église
elles m'ont partagé
la situation
j'ai dit
voici un travail
pour les diacres
est-ce que je peux
partager
cette situation
au diacre
la famille est d'accord
et j'ai dit
un diacre
et il m'a dit
ok
je vais m'occuper
ça sera réglé
etc
et donc moi
je dois me reposer
car
la parole
d'un diacre
devrait être
l'une des paroles
les plus fiables
au sein d'une église
et donc là
c'est très important
qu'il ne soit pas
de double langage
ou de double coeur
car
les doubles langages
représentent toujours
les doubles coeurs
et donc seulement
la crainte de Dieu
peut bannir
en fait
cette tendance
que nous avons
en fait
de choisir
des paroles
parfois flatteuses
lorsqu'on pense
une chose
et qu'on dit d'autres
et ça ne devrait pas
être les qualifications
pour un diacre
voilà pourquoi
c'est important
d'avoir cette crainte
de Dieu
ensuite il dit
exempte
ou éloigné
de l'excès
du vent
et donc
ils non seulement
sont appelés
à maîtriser
leur langue
ils sont aussi
appelés
à maîtriser
leur appétit
et là
c'est intéressant
exempte
du vent
c'est quelque chose
d'important
quand on pense
à comment
ça peut être
nuisible
ok
en fait
c'est intéressant
il faut qu'on soit
conscient
quand nous sommes
en garde
et hors garde
quelque part
et donc
bien sûr
qu'ici
il y a
on va dire
une invitation
des communions
où les diacres
ne laissent jamais
d'être diacres
mais il peut avoir
la possibilité
d'avoir une communion
avec les frères et sœurs
et que cette communion
soit plutôt
en détente
mais
ce n'est pas
forcément nécessaire
qu'il soit
complètement abstinent
de prendre en verre
etc
par contre
si
cette personne
est en train
de traiter
une situation
importante
des réconciliations
ou de traiter
un besoin
dans une famille
il est en garde
il est en train
d'exercer son office
et à ce moment-là
il doit être
sobre
et gérer les choses
de la manière
la plus raisonnable
possible
il faut
d'inspirer
ses respects
envers la communauté
il est important
car pour plus
d'intimité
qu'on puisse développer
avec ses frères
qui est un membre
de la famille de la foi
je dois me rappeler
en fait
qu'il a été revêtu
d'autorité
pour exercer un office
et cet office
qu'il va exercer
il doit inspirer
les respects
et donc
on doit adapter
quelque part
un traitement
à la manière
dont on va
exercer
ou régler
un affaire
au sein de l'église
et donc c'est important
que cette personne-là
elle ait conscience
que non
aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le jour
pour prendre le verre
je suis venu
c'est la famille des fois
mais je suis là
pour traiter
les problèmes
que cette famille traverse
que ses membres traversent
et nous allons les traiter
et c'est intéressant
l'autre aspect
c'est
comment les vents
peuvent nuire
les raisonnements
comment il peut
empêcher cette personne
d'avoir les bonnes limites
pour savoir
jusqu'à où je dois écouter
comment je dois conseiller
comment juger cette affaire
comment ne pas me laisser
guider en fait
par les favoritisme
l'intimité que je puisse avoir
comment rester impartial
et tout cela va traverser
l'usage
les plus sobres
de la conscience
de la raison
et donc là
c'est important
d'avoir
un raisonnement clair
et un contrôle
de soi-même
et bien sûr
qu'il y a toujours
l'implication
quand on pense
à l'excès
de manière générale
à la maîtrise
de soi
à tous égards
donc là
dans cette retraite
l'une des choses
qui nous a été communiquée
c'est
notre corps
est quelque part
une expression
de notre piété
de notre
crainte
de Dieu
de notre
envie
de plaire Dieu
par les disciplines
qu'on a
et donc si
l'église
est une communauté
formée par des personnes
qui ont une envie
une volonté
prédominante
qui c'est la volonté
de Dieu
et du Saint-Esprit
envers notre
sanctification
à tous égards
attention
mais qu'en même temps
chaque individu
a une bataille
chez lui
entre
les tentations
charnelles
intellectuelles
d'orgueil
peu importe
on a des nombres
infinis de péchés
qu'on pourrait nommer
la réalité
c'est que chacun
d'entre nous
a une force
prédominante
une volonté
et une puissance
mise à disposition
pour nous scientifier
et nous avons tous
une volonté
de la chair
qui lutte contre
cette volonté
prédominante
du Saint-Esprit
par contre
chez ceux
en qui
les Saint-Esprit
prédominent davantage
remplis du Saint-Esprit
il va
maîtriser davantage
ses faiblesses
et donc
cette maîtrise
de soi
s'applique
non seulement
au vent
mais à tout appétit
démodéré
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
et donc
c'est important
que cette personne
ait cette maîtrise
de soi
et ensuite
la parole nous dit
qu'ils soient aussi
éloignés
des gants
honteux
les diacres
qui accomplissent
leur mandat biblique
doivent contrôler
leur parole
leur appétit
et aussi
leur portefeuille
c'est important
car
à plusieurs reprises
les diacres
sont responsables
de gérer
l'argent de l'église
et donc
en acte 6
il était responsable
de rassembler
quelques dons
pour pourvoir
aux nourritures
et la réalité
c'est que
dans l'histoire
de l'église
on voit
que c'était
un exercice
qu'ils ont
à plusieurs reprises
développé
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
en fait
que quand il dit
les gants honteux
c'est très large
et
quand on considère
les autres passages
des lettres pastorales
les dirigeants
de l'église
sont toujours
encouragés
à s'enfuir
du désir
d'être riche
qu'on soit clair
Dieu
dans sa générosité
peut décider
de faire prospérer
certaines personnes
et lorsque les personnes
prospèrent
par la grâce
de Dieu
qu'est-ce qui peut faire
un chrétien prospérer
les mêmes choses
que j'ai parlé
par rapport aux puritans
si on travaille
honnêtement
avec excellence
pour la gloire
de Dieu
les plus probable
c'est qu'on va
prospérer
même si
notre cœur
n'est pas
dans ses désirs
car on travaille
avec excellence
honnêtement
intégrité
travail dur
comme la Bible
nous enseigne
par contre
même si Dieu
dans sa grâce
dans sa providence
sa souveraineté
peut faire
certaines personnes
qui ne sont pas
en train de chercher
cela
prospérer
c'est que Dieu
dirige les chrétiens
à n'est pas désirer
c'est
les désirs
de l'argent
donc l'argent
elle peut être
quelque chose
de neutre
Jésus nous présente
comme une chose
potentiellement
à l'éminence
constante
de nous corrompre
c'est les mamons
de l'iniquité
donc là
il n'y a pas
de neutralité
c'est quelque chose
qui sera toujours
en train de tenter
notre cœur
à substituer
les lieux des dieux
dans notre cœur
si on a beaucoup
d'argent
on a l'impression
qu'on n'a pas besoin
de la protection divine
de la provision divine
etc.
on a l'impression
que l'argent
parle la langue
du monde entier
on peut avoir
l'impression
qu'elle a plus
de puissance
qu'elle n'a
mais la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
la possibilité
de faire l'usage
de l'argent
pour la gloire
de Dieu
si Dieu
ne fait prospérer
qu'elle est
les mandats bibliques
dignité
vie avec dignité
pour moi
et tout ce qui surmonte
pour promouvoir
l'homme de Dieu
comme disait John Wesley
dès que l'argent
arrive sur mes mains
je les passe
en avant
vers les rômes
de Dieu
pour qu'elles
ne prennent pas
les chemins
de mon cœur
donc c'est légitime
de chercher
à voir la dignité
dans la vie
mais ce qui va
surabonder
c'est pour la gloire
des dieux
et la réalité
c'est que particulièrement
les leaders
de l'église
doivent être caractérisés
par un détachement
de l'argent
aimer
l'amour
de l'argent
est une des racines
de tous les mots
la Bible
elle est très claire
là-dessus
et surtout ceux
qui vont gérer
les finances
de l'église
doivent le faire
une chose importante
à remarquer ici
c'est possible
qu'un homme de Dieu
rempli de son esprit
traverse des moments
de difficultés
dans la vie
car Dieu peut décider
cela
pour qu'il grandisse
dans la foi
mais c'est clair aussi
que
de gérer bien
l'argent
et les finances
de travailler bien
de travailler pour la gloire
des dieux
et de se planifier
est une évidence
d'une personne
qui est
bien ordonnée
c'est une évidence
de l'oeuvre
de Saint-Esprit
et c'est intéressant
en fait
que quand on considère
un homme
pour les ministères
des diacres
c'est l'une des choses
qu'on doit considérer
cette tentation
pour les gants
honteux
s'affiche
parfois
dans des conversations
avec des personnes
qui sont véritablement
chrétiennes
mais qui cherchent
toujours à trouver
une solution
que l'argent
arrive plus vite
arrive plus facilement
qui considèrent
par exemple
à chaque opportunité
j'ai déjà vécu
cette expérience
avec un frère
dans mon église
précédente
chaque opportunité
qu'une grande
entreprise
a commis
une erreur
ils veulent profiter
et comme on dit
en français
indemniser
et prendre
c'est comme ça
qu'on dit
et prendre
une indemnisation
pour prendre
l'avantage
ces manières
de se structurer
dans la vie
de s'habituer
sont en train
de donner
des signes
très clairs
c'est pas
les moyens
bibliques
c'est pas
les principes
bibliques
pour
gagner la vie
honnêtement
il y aura
certains cas
on a souffert
un vrai préjudice
et c'est juste
de demander
la compensation
mais
il y a certains
qui sont
constamment
en train de chercher
au lieu de faire
cet escalier
petit à petit
persévérer
dans un travail
parfois difficile
dur
en France
je pense qu'une des choses
qu'on devrait faire attention
c'est la facilité
donc l'état
peut nous aider
et une invitation
à une attitude
un peu victimiste
je ne suis pas en train
de dire que ce soit
tous les cas
que ce soit clair
car c'est important
de défendre aussi
les droits
des travailleurs
c'est clair
il y a beaucoup plus
d'abus dans d'autres nations
mais une tentation
pour les chrétiens
dans cette culture
c'est
de compter
trop avec
l'aide du gouvernement
ou ces droits
des travailleurs
et planifier
une vie
qui n'est pas
trop active
constamment
en train de produire
comme la parole
de Dieu
nous enseigne
à faire
qu'est-ce qu'il peut
dire
travailler avec
vos proprements
afin
d'avoir
avec quoi
vous maintenir
et pouvoir
aussi aider
à ceux qui sont
dans les besoins
donc
l'obstination
de chrétien
c'est travailler
avec quelque chose
de digne
avec ses proprements
afin d'avoir
et afin de passer
en avance
et donc
ces gants sordides
peuvent ne pas être
directement
quelque chose
d'injuste
des pécheresses
!
mais ça peut être
aussi ces manières
qui sont
qui déshonorent
en fait
les principes
publics
pour le travail
pour la manière
dont on devrait
produire quelque chose
pour la communauté
donc c'est important
de considérer
que les diacres
c'est quelqu'un
qui est qualifié
à cet égard
si cette personne
traverse un moment
dans la vie
où ses finances
ne sont pas
très bien structurées
et qui ont confié
à cette personne
la gestion de l'argent
on est en train
d'exposer
cette personne
à la tentation
et nous sommes
possiblement
en train de considérer
qu'elle n'est peut-être
pas qualifiée
car elle n'a pas
bien géré
ses finances
et donc la providence
des dieux
elle confirme aussi
par ses voies
mais ce n'est pas
pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas
des voies
d'amélioration
des développements
car une personne
qui par exemple
est très jeune
dans les débuts
de sa vie
en train de faire
ses études
c'est compréhensible
donc on ne va pas
dire
il n'est pas
bien structuré
financièrement
donc on ne va pas
considérer
non ce n'est pas
les cas
mais si jamais
il est ordonné
diacre
l'église doit être
responsable
à protéger
aussi cette personne
de ne pas
l'exposer
à la tentation
mon église précédente
il y a eu un cas
d'un diacre
qui était
très fidèle
tant que les choses
allaient bien
dans sa vie
mais à un moment donné
il a continué
à gérer
les finances
de l'église
et il était
dans un moment
très difficile
et là
il est tombé
dans ses péchés
il est dévié
un peu
de l'argeur
de l'église
et ça a fini
très mal pour lui
même avec un jugement
temporel des dieux
vers sa vie
donc les dieux vivants
qui ont les ailes
pour la vérité
surtout dans une église
qui cherche
à être fidèle à Dieu
et remplie de Saint-Esprit
c'est là
où on va entendre
des histoires
très sévères
donc c'est très important
de considérer
cette réalité
il faut inspirer
la crainte
à cet égard
donc il ne peut pas
avoir
cette tentation
de parler plus
des choses terrestres
que spirituelles
que sa parole
que ses mots
nous parlent du ciel
mais son cœur
est clairement dans la terre
il faut que cette personne
soit cohérente
dans sa manière de vie
et qu'il soit
quelqu'un
capable
donc parfois
on est tenté
il y a des personnes
qui ont prospéré
énormément
et le problème
c'est que ceux
qui prospèrent
parfois les plus
dans cette vie
ce sont des personnes
qui aiment le plus
l'argent
et qui veulent
les chercher
à la première place
et l'église
ne peut pas
dire non plus
voici cette personne
qui a prospéré
qui gère bien
ses finances
viens s'il te plaît
prendre soin
de l'argent
de l'église
et mépriser
des personnes
qui allaient avoir
plutôt des instants
beaucoup plus
généreux
et qui ont une vie
modeste
mais bien ordonnée
digne
mais qui seraient
beaucoup plus disposées
à raisonner
que ce soit
pour la générosité
ou que ce soit
pour épargner
ceux qui n'épargnent
parfois
ils aiment aussi
beaucoup l'argent
et donc
ce sont des choses
qu'on doit considérer
donc voilà
exemple
des gants honteux
et c'est donc
la quatrième qualité
qui nous parle
des qualités
personnelles
donc dignité
exemple
des duplicités
de l'excès
des vents
exemple
des gants
honteux
on va s'arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
et continuer
avec les qualifications
relationnelles
pour la prochaine fois
voilà
on va s'arrêter
pour la prochaine fois